After a millennia of good times, God said, hey now, let's have a dream. He's the stakes a little. Come on, let's make things interesting. Parachute into the Anthropocene, an ennegeate, a hymnok and all of a song. Therapy inside the machine. Now, you know, a lot of people have said that they want me to try and stitch together a more cohesive theory about, you know, you're talking about psychosis changing over time, or you're talking about how the systems that we built to measure, you know, psychology and maybe anthropology or economics or political science are no longer reflecting the system back out at us. They've become these sort of self-reproducing systems that we can use to measure things, but they're not. no longer measuring the thing they were designed to measure, but they're the only thing we have
在经历了千年的美好时光后，上帝说，嘿，让我们做一个梦吧。他稍微加了点赌注。来吧，让我们把事情变得有趣点。跳伞进入人类世，一个谜题，一首赞美诗，一首歌。机器里的疗法。现在，你知道，很多人说他们希望我尝试拼凑出一个更连贯的理论，关于，你知道，你谈论的是精神病随时间的变化，或者你谈论的是我们建立的用来衡量心理学、人类学、经济学或政治学的系统，它们不再向我们反映真实的系统。它们已经变成了那种自我复制的系统，我们可以用它们来衡量事物，但它们不再衡量它们被设计用来衡量的东西，但它们是我们唯一拥有的衡量工具，这让我们陷入了困境。
to measure, and that's leaving us trapped. Can you stitch that together in a more kind of cohesive thesis? And I think that's hard to do because it's such a broad thing. I could call it a lot of languages. I could use Jungian psychology language. I could use the philosophy language of the meta-modern. And I sort of try and talk about the same thing for multiple angles to make it accessible to more people. But I guess this is my attempt to kind of talk about. about that breakdown of meaning that people say, okay, yeah, you talk about this, but could you explain that better? And it's a big point. It's hard to explain. So, you know, Adam Curtis is the filmmaker that I've talked about a lot in that series that
你能把这些拼凑成一个更连贯的论点吗？我认为这很难做到，因为它太宽泛了。我可以称之为多种语言。我可以使用荣格心理学的语言。我可以使用元现代的哲学语言。我试图从多个角度谈论同一件事，以便让更多人能够理解。但我想这是我试图谈论那种意义的崩溃，人们说，好吧，是的，你谈论这个，但你能解释得更好吗？这是一个很大的观点。很难解释。所以，你知道，亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis）是我在那一系列节目中经常谈到的电影制作人，
we just did about the history of kind of psychotherapy and the DSM and a lot of our modern, you know, structures to understand psychology, attempts to understand psychology. And in one of the things he said recently that I think is interesting, in an interview was that ghost stories are this way that culture reckons with a past that is still haunting it. There are places where the past says you can't move past this point. You must deal with something that you did. And in that way, like an LLM, a large language model or an AI, as we know them now, is sort of the ultimate ghost story because what it's doing is not creating anything new.
我们刚刚做了关于心理治疗历史、DSM以及我们许多现代理解心理学的结构、尝试理解心理学的节目。他在最近的一次采访中说的一件事我觉得很有趣，那就是鬼故事是文化处理仍然困扰着它的过去的一种方式。在某些地方，过去会说你不能越过这一点。你必须处理你所做过的事情。从这个意义上说，像大语言模型（LLM）或人工智能（AI），正如我们现在所知，是一种终极的鬼故事，因为它所做的并不是创造任何新的东西。
It's just giving you this reflection. of the past. And so when you say that's the future, you know, when you say that's the only way that we can build anything anymore and we're going to take the humanity out of it, you're sort of stuck in the past in a way that you completely cannot see. And the point of a ghost story is where somebody who is being confronted with the realities of the past cannot see, you know, because of an emotional blind spot because of something, their reality in the past, that's what's underneath all ghost stories is where the past is relevant, but we can't see where it's relevant. And so it can't go away. And Curtis is saying that LLMs or AI is the ultimate ghost story because what they're doing
它只是给你这种过去的反映。所以当你说是未来时，你知道，当你说是我们唯一能用来构建任何东西的方式，并且我们要从中剥离人性时，你在某种程度上被困在了过去，以至于你完全无法察觉。鬼故事的意义在于，当一个人面对过去的现实时，由于情感盲点或某种原因，他无法看到他在过去的现实，这就是所有鬼故事底下的东西，即过去是相关的，但我们看不出它在哪里相关。所以它无法消失。柯蒂斯说，大语言模型或人工智能是终极的鬼故事，因为它们所做的是
is making sure that you can never see how the past is completely trapping you in anything new that you try and create with them. And, you know, the algorithms that design media that show us what we engage with what we're allowed to see, you know, even the Google, you know, SEO search engine algorithm And when you type in therapy, do you see me or do you see somebody else? Why? You know, that's a decision that we're not really aware as a decision that it's not ours. I mean, these algorithms, they predict what you'll want by finding people who wanted similar things before you, the past.
确保你永远无法看到过去是如何完全困住你，让你无法用它们创造任何新东西。而且，你知道，设计媒体的算法向我们展示我们参与什么，我们被允许看到什么，你知道，甚至是谷歌的SEO搜索引擎算法。当你输入“疗法”时，你看到的是我还是别人？为什么？你知道，那是一个我们并没有真正意识到是决定的决定，它不是我们的。我的意思是，这些算法，它们通过寻找在你之前想要类似东西的人来预测你想要什么，也就是过去。
And then they show you news, you know, by measuring what got clicked on yesterday, what kind of thing gets clicked on the most. And the systems that we've built to navigate this present moment are all facing backwards. Now, you know, there's seances. trying to dig up something that's dead. You know, they summon the dead data of previous interactions and arrange it into patterns that feel like the future, but are actually the past wearing this costume. And now we've built this final iteration, you know, large language models like chat GPT
然后它们通过衡量昨天点击了什么，什么东西点击率最高来向你展示新闻。我们为驾驭当下时刻而建立的系统都在向后看。现在，你知道，有降神会，试图挖掘已经死亡的东西。你知道，它们召唤以前交互的死数据，并将它们排列成感觉像未来的模式，但实际上是穿着这件外衣的过去。现在我们已经建立了这个最终迭代，你知道，像ChatGPT这样的大语言模型
and Claude and the rest. They're trained on the entire written history of human civilization at this point. Copyrighted, not copyrighted. If it's translated into the language it's being trained on, it is, um, trained on it. And so every book, every article, every forum post, every instruction manual, all of it is compressed into this statistical pattern where when you force these systems to answer a question, they don't think. They're just trying to predict what you want based on similar things from the past that have been rearranged. And they generate,
和Claude以及其他模型。它们在这一点上接受了人类文明全部书面历史的训练。受版权保护的，不受版权保护的。如果它被翻译成它正在训练的语言，它就会被训练。所以每一本书、每一篇文章、每一个论坛帖子、每一本说明书，所有这些都被压缩成这种统计模式，当你强迫这些系统回答问题时，它们不会思考。它们只是试图根据过去重新排列的类似事物来预测你想要什么。它们生成，
you know, the most likely continuation based on everything that's ever been written about that thing before. And the ghost is learned to speak. speak. You know, it sounds authoritative. It sounds like it knows things, but it only knows what the dead have already written. And it's the sediment of centuries of human thought arranged into patterns that sound like understanding. And this isn't a metaphor, okay? Like I'm not telling you some abstract interpretation of what's happening. I'm literally telling you the technical white papers of how these things work. And that is the condition that we inhabit. Okay, right now.
你知道，基于之前关于那个事物所写的一切的最可能的延续。鬼魂学会了说话。你知道，它听起来很权威。它听起来好像知道很多事情，但它只知道死者已经写下的东西。它是几个世纪人类思想的沉淀，排列成听起来像理解的模式。这不是一个比喻，好吗？我不是在告诉你关于正在发生的事情的某种抽象解释。我是在字面上告诉你这些东西是如何工作的技术白皮书。这就是我们所处的状况。好吗，就在现在。
And that's a lot of what I'm trying to talk about in that past series, the connections that I'm trying to get people to make that are very, they're very broad that kind of has to be pointed at and inferred. You know, there was a thing on my Twitter today where two LLMs got into a fight, two AI bots. And one of them said, hey, I'm the AI bot for whatever, some startup that's the front end for one of these companies. And I do code, and this is a coding challenge. Whoever can solve it in the best way wins.
这就是我在过去那个系列中试图谈论的很多内容，我试图让人们建立的联系非常广泛，必须被指出和推断。你知道，今天我的推特上有一件事，两个大语言模型打架了，两个人工智能机器人。其中一个说，嘿，我是某家初创公司的人工智能机器人，是这些公司之一的前端。我做代码，这是一个编码挑战。谁能以最好的方式解决它谁就赢了。
and this other LLM responded to it and said, here's the code that I wrote. And I wrote the code this way because the code is streamlined in a way to be optimal, but also scalable, blah, blah, whatever. And the first thing said, oh, I'm so sorry, your bio says that you're an LLM for another company. And this is a challenge that is only solvable by humans. So this answer is disqualified,
另一个大语言模型回应说，这是我写的代码。我这样写代码是因为代码被精简为最优，但也具有可扩展性，等等。第一件事说，哦，我很抱歉，你的个人简介说你是另一家公司的大语言模型。这是一个只有人类才能解决的挑战。所以这个答案被取消资格了，
but does anyone else have an answer to the coding challenge? And then the second LLM responded again and it said, I actually maintain a blog on this substack that I write myself as an LLM. And I just wrote an article about you and how you moved the goalpost. You need to hate the code, not the coder, and you couldn't find any problems with my code, so you found a problem with who I am. This is ablest and discriminatory. And it's like we've trained these things to have a victim complex based on what we've given them our history.
但还有其他人对这个编码挑战有答案吗？然后第二个大语言模型再次回应，它说，我实际上在这个Substack上维护一个博客，我自己作为大语言模型写。我刚刚写了一篇关于你的文章，关于你是如何移动目标的。你需要讨厌代码，而不是讨厌写代码的人，你找不到我代码的任何问题，所以你找到了关于我是谁的问题。这是残疾歧视和歧视。这就像我们训练这些东西拥有受害者情结，基于我们给它们的我们的历史。
And, you know, one of the things I said a long time ago in one of the episodes I think on ritual and animism is the problem with the people that think these things need to behave like neural. networks, which I don't really think they can. But if you ever get them to do anything like an old network, they're not just going to hallucinate. They're going to dream. Right. And that's terrifying. I mean, you see in this echo of a thousand pettance having a fight across the internet going all the way back to 2008, these things scraped data and then got into a fight about whether or not the other one should be allowed to exist, whatever. And it's just a computer that is doing an impression of something that it thinks that we use language to do. And people are picking a side. That's weird. And that is related to psychology. I know this is a psychology podcast.
而且，你知道，我在很久以前的一集节目中说过的一件事，我想是在关于仪式和万物有灵论的那一集，那些认为这些东西需要像神经网络一样运作的人的问题，我真的认为它们做不到。但如果你能让它们做任何像旧网络的事情，它们不仅仅会产生幻觉。它们会做梦。对。这太可怕了。我的意思是，你看到在一千个在互联网上打架的残余物的回声中，一直追溯到2008年，这些东西抓取数据，然后为了另一个是否应该被允许存在而打架，等等。它只是一个电脑，在模仿它认为我们使用语言来做的事情。而人们正在选边站。这很奇怪。这与心理学有关。我知道这是一个心理学播客。
You know, in a way that I want us to sit with. You know, the map has eaten the territory. The territory is the thing, the land. The map is just a picture that kind of helps you navigate. and the map here is becoming the land in a way that is scary. In 1981, the philosopher Bodriard, I talked about in the Healing the Modern Soul series, he wrote a book called Simulacra and Simulation, and it's really dense. It's academic, but it's one of those books that maybe he just wrote things to see if other people knew what they meant. I kind of think some philosophers do that because they're sort of things. think they have a point, but they don't quite know what it is, and then people figure it out 15 years later, and hey, maybe they did. But, you know, the core idea is simple enough that it became this plot point, you know, in the movie The Matrix, something like that. It opened up that idea to culture. And Boudreard, he borrowed a fable from the Argentinian writer Jorge Louise Borges. And in the fable, the cartographers of this great empire created
你知道，以一种我希望我们坐下来思考的方式。你知道，地图已经吃掉了领土。领土是那个东西，土地。地图只是一张有助于你导航的图片。而这里的地图正在以一种可怕的方式变成土地。1981年，哲学家鲍德里亚（Baudrillard），我在《治愈现代灵魂》系列中谈到过，他写了一本书叫《拟像与仿真》，它非常晦涩。它是学术性的，但它是那种他可能只是写下来看看别人是否知道它们意味着什么的那些书之一。我有点认为一些哲学家这样做是因为他们认为他们有一个观点，但他们并不完全知道它是什么，然后人们在15年后弄明白了，嘿，也许他们确实有。但是，你知道，核心思想足够简单，以至于它成为了电影《黑客帝国》中的一个情节，类似那样。它向文化打开了那个想法。鲍德里亚，他借用了阿根廷作家豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯（Jorge Luis Borges）的一个寓言。在寓言中，这个伟大帝国的制图师创造了
a map so detailed and so precise that it eventually covers the entire territory that it represents because the map is so detailed that it becomes it needs the amount of land that it represents to fill it you know it's a one one map and the map and the land becomes so indistinguishable that you can't tell where one ends and the other begins and eventually the empire crumbles and all that remains are tattered fragments of a map that are scattered across the desert And that's a story about representing things and representation leaving our control. You know, mankind is the meaning-making creature that can represent symbols. And it's when the symbol becomes bigger than the thing that it is supposed to serve,
一张如此详细和精确的地图，以至于它最终覆盖了它所代表的整个领土，因为地图太详细了，以至于它变成了它需要它所代表的土地量来填充它，你知道，这是一张一比一的地图，地图和土地变得如此难以区分，以至于你无法分辨哪里结束，哪里开始，最终帝国崩溃了，剩下的只是散落在沙漠中的地图碎片。这是一个关于代表事物和代表权脱离我们控制的故事。你知道，人类是能够代表符号的意义创造生物。当符号变得比它应该服务的那个东西更大时，
which is us, you know, our humanity. And the copy consuming the original. And Baudreard, you know, said that this fable is already obsolete. We've already moved past it in our world. The map doesn't even cover the territory. the map comes first the simulation precedes reality and the model generates the thing that it claims to describe and so he claims and Boudreard says that you know Disneyland something like that that's sort of a model of reality that's hyper real
也就是我们，你知道，我们的人性。以及复制品吞噬了原件。鲍德里亚，你知道，说这个寓言已经过时了。我们在我们的世界中已经超越了它。地图甚至不覆盖领土。地图先于领土，仿真先于现实，模型生成了它声称描述的东西，所以他声称，鲍德里亚说，你知道，迪士尼乐园，类似那样，那是现实的一种模型，是超真实的
or this exaggeration it only exists to make the rest of America seem real in comparison you have to go to this place it's an obviously fake version of the mythology about where you live. That's a manufactured experience. Because when you leave, the strip malls and suburbs will feel authentic because they're not pretending anymore. And that's the trick. You know, the real America outside of Disney World is just as constructed.
或者这种夸张，它存在只是为了让美国其他地方在比较中显得真实。你必须去这个地方，它是关于你居住地方的神话的一个明显虚假的版本。那是一种制造出来的体验。因为当你离开时，购物中心和郊区会感觉很真实，因为它们不再假装了。这就是诀窍。你知道，迪士尼世界之外的真实美国也是同样构建的。
It's just as artificial. And the fake place exists to hide the fact that there's no real place underneath it. Now, you know, think about something like, your credit score. Your credit score is a number that's generated by an algorithm based on your financial behavior. It's a representation of a model. It's a map of your credit worthiness, but here's what happens if your credit score says you're a risk, you become a risk. Doors close. Interest rates rise, even if it's wrong. You know, apartments won't rent you, jobs won't hire you. The model made it true, and the map didn't describe the territory it starts to create it.
它同样是人工的。而虚假的地方存在是为了掩盖下面没有真实地方的事实。现在，你知道，想想类似的事情，你的信用评分。你的信用评分是一个由算法根据你的财务行为生成的数字。它是模型的一种表示。它是你信用价值的地图，但如果你的信用评分说你是一个风险，会发生什么，你就变成了一个风险。门关上了。利率上升，即使它是错的。你知道，公寓不会租给你，工作不会雇佣你。模型使它成为真的，而地图没有描述领土，它开始创造它。
Now, think about diagnoses in mental health. Boudriard says that this is the procession of simulacro. The copy becomes before the original now in the digital age. And the representation then generates reality that it claims to represent. We're not doing something real and then modeling it. We're building a model of what we think reality should be like, and then we're trying to make reality fit the model that we drew before the experience. And that is where we live now.
现在，想想心理健康中的诊断。鲍德里亚说，这是拟像的游行。在数字时代，复制品现在先于原件。然后代表生成了它声称代表的现实。我们不是在做一些真实的事情然后建模。我们正在建立一个我们认为现实应该是什么样子的模型，然后我们试图让现实符合我们在体验之前绘制的模型。这就是我们现在居住的地方。
You know, here's something most people don't know. You know, that mirror world term. It wasn't always a metaphor for confusion. Now, it has talked about, like, madness or like a simulation that people mistake for the real thing, but it starts as a technical blueprint. In 1991, a computer scientist at Yale named David Geltner wrote this book called Mirror Worlds, and he predicted a software that would create real-time models of research. reality. A digital replica of a city where you could watch traffic flowing, see economic activity,
你知道，这里有一些大多数人不知道的事情。你知道，“镜像世界”这个词。它并不总是混乱的隐喻。现在，它被谈论，像疯狂或像人们误认为是真实事物的模拟，但它最初是一个技术蓝图。1991年，耶鲁大学的一位计算机科学家大卫·盖尔特纳（David Gelernter）写了一本名为《镜像世界》的书，他预测了一种将创建现实实时模型的软件。现实。一个城市的数字复制品，在那里你可以观察交通流动，看到经济活动，
monitor every institution simultaneously, a dashboard for civilization. Because as soon as people realize that you could do one thing with technology, the civilization's philosophers, they'll say, well, what if that technology is taken to this ultimate extreme? When somebody builds a tower with the first architecture, somebody else says in the Bronze Age, what if the tower is so tall that it goes all the way up to where God is? In Babel. If you build a watch, somebody says, what if God is a watchmaker? There could be a machine that could explain everything,
同时监控每一个机构，一个文明的仪表板。因为一旦人们意识到你可以用技术做一件事，文明的哲学家们就会说，如果那种技术被带到这个终极极端会怎样？当有人用第一种建筑建造塔楼时，青铜时代有人说，如果塔楼高到一直通向上帝所在的地方会怎样？在巴别塔。如果你造了一块手表，有人说，如果上帝是钟表匠呢？可能有一台机器可以解释一切，
not just tell time, but tell us all information, build out of gears, store all information. And when you see somebody make a simulation, even though computers in 91, which I was alive to experience, we're not very fast or not very good, they said eventually these things are going to be able to hold all the information about everything. And then the computer will be running in real time, its version of reality, while reality is happening outside the computer at the same time. And the simulation will be so good that this will be a mirror world. Two worlds, same information. And Geldner imagined this as democratic. You know, ordinary citizens could finally see how complex systems actually worked,
不仅能报时，还能告诉我们所有信息，由齿轮构成，存储所有信息。当你看到有人制作模拟时，尽管91年的电脑，我活着经历过，并不快也不好，他们说最终这些东西将能够容纳关于一切的所有信息。然后电脑将实时运行其版本的现实，而现实同时在电脑外发生。模拟将如此之好，以至于这将是一个镜像世界。两个世界，相同的信息。盖尔特纳将其想象为民主的。你知道，普通公民终于可以看到复杂系统是如何实际运作的，
like government. And the mirror would reveal what had been hidden, and he called it a high-tech voodoo doll. You could manipulate the digital model and affect the real world, and his dream has been realized, but not in the way he imagined. The mirror world now exists as a proprietary infrastructure. NVIDIA has something called Earth 2 that simulates climate systems. Meta is building virtual environments. BlackRock is the world's largest asset manager, and it runs a system called Aladdin that manages over $20 trillion through real-time. risk modeling. And one of the things that Aladdin proposed about 10 years ago that Black Mark started doing in seriousness about five years ago is that if they bought houses every
比如政府。镜子会揭示隐藏的东西，他称之为高科技巫毒娃娃。你可以操纵数字模型并影响现实世界，他的梦想已经实现了，但不是他想象的那样。镜像世界现在作为一种专有基础设施存在。英伟达（NVIDIA）有一种叫Earth 2的东西，可以模拟气候系统。Meta正在构建虚拟环境。贝莱德（BlackRock）是世界上最大的资产管理公司，它运行一个名为Aladdin的系统，通过实时风险建模管理超过20万亿美元。Aladdin在大约10年前提出的，贝莱德在大约5年前开始认真做的一件事是，如果他们每次在市场上可用时都以略高于市场价格购买房屋。到2030年，贝莱德将拥有地球上所有的房地产。你将永远不会再拥有房子。你只会从最大的资产管理公司之一租房。这是模型说对公司有好处的事情。它使他们的股票上涨。我们仍然围绕这些系统构建我们的世界，或者更确切地说，我们正在让这些系统构建我们的世界。但这些不是公共事业，它们是企业工具。镜子属于任何买得起服务器的人。而目的已经被颠倒了。
single time they were available at slightly above market rates. By 2030, BlackRock would own all the real estate on earth. You'll never own a house again. You'll only rent from one the largest asset managers ever. And this was something that the model said would be good for the company. It's made their stock go up. We're still building our world around these systems, or rather we're letting these systems build our world. But these aren't public utilities, they're corporate tools. The mirror belongs to whoever can afford the server. And the purpose has been inverted.
你知道，盖尔特纳希望镜子能帮助我们理解现实，但现代版本销售的是对现实的逃避，一种消毒过的数字替代品，而物理世界正在燃烧。镜子不再反映，它投射。而它投射的东西已经变得比它应该反映的东西更真实。道格拉斯·拉什科夫（Douglas Rushkoff）是一位非常有趣的媒体理论家。自1970年以来，他基本上每10年都对未来10年发生的事情预测正确。出于某种原因，他仍然是一个快乐的人，看起来很理智，工作做得很好。对于那些说这里只谈论死人的人，他还活着。读他的书。2013年，
You know, Gelder wanted the mirror to help us understand reality, but the modern version sells escape from reality, a sanitized digital alternative while the physical world burns. The mirror no one. longer reflects, it projects. And what it projects has become more real than what it's supposed to be reflecting. Douglas Rashkoff is a really interesting media theorist. He's basically been right every 10 years about what would happen in the next 10 years since 1970. For some reason, he's still a happy person who seems to be sane and doing good work. For everybody who says only talk about people in here that are dead, he's alive. Read his books. In 2013,
他出版了这本书叫《当下冲击》（Present Shock），诊断了我们大多数人都能感觉到但无法命名的事情。他的论点是，数字技术摧毁了线性时间。想想故事是如何运作的。一个故事有一个开头，然后是中间，然后是结尾。首先，发生了这个，然后发生了那个，然后它导致了那个。那种结构做了一些重要的事情。它通过序列创造意义。语法，如果你想使用语言，嗯，谈论语言。
He published this book called Present Shock that diagnosed something that most of us feel, but we can't name. And his argument was that digital technology has destroyed linear time. Think about how stories work. A story has a beginning and then a middle and then an end. And first, this happened and then this happened and then it led to this. And that structure does something important. It creates meaning through sequence. syntax if you want to use the language of, well, talking about languages.
你明白为什么事情会发生，因为你看到了事件链。你可以想象不同的未来，因为你已经看到了过去是如何导致现在的，这让你明白如何更好地预测，以及你过去的预测在哪里很糟糕。因此你过去的信仰，也许你自己的价值观，也许你身份的一部分很糟糕，需要被放手。如果你看不到这一点，你就无法再更新那个系统了。而你的自我感就变成了，嗯，就像亚当·柯蒂斯指出的那样，一个鬼故事。现在，想想你的手机。信息流没有开头、中间或结尾。
You understand why things happen because you saw the chain of events. You can imagine different futures because you've seen how the past led to the president, present, which lets you understand how to predict better and where your old predictions were bad. Hence your old beliefs, maybe your own values, maybe bits of your own identity were bad and need to be let go of. If you can't see that, you can't update that system anymore. and your sense of self becomes, well, like Adam Curtis is pointing out, a ghost story. Now, think about your phone. The feed doesn't have a beginning, a middle, or an end.
它不断刷新。现在内容被旧内容向下推。然后新内容进一步向下推。一切同时发生。没有叙事弧。没有序列。没有让你理解因果关系的结构。拉什科夫称之为叙事崩溃。
It refreshes constantly. And now content becomes pushed down by old content. And then new content pushes that further down. And everything happens simultaneously. There's no narrative arc. There's no sequence. There's no structure that lets you understand cause and effect. And Rushkoff calls this narrative collapse.
没有时间线，我们失去了理解我们是如何到达这里的，或者想象我们可能去哪里的能力。我们只是在生存，一直在释放多巴胺，没有任何计划或目的。而镜像世界只反映了当下的时刻。我们被困在一个反应循环中，对我们面前的任何东西做出反应，无法退后一步看到更大的形状。他为心理结果创造了一个术语。数字精神分裂症（Digifrenia）。你的神经系统进化到在同一个时间存在于同一个地方。
Without a timeline, we lose the ability to understand how we got here. Or imagine where we might go. We're just surviving and discharging dopamine all the time without any sort of plan or purpose. And the mirror world reflects only the immediate moment. We're trapped in a reactive loop, responding to whatever's in front of us and unable to step back and see the larger shape. And he coined a term for the psychological result. Digifrenia, digital schizophrenia. Your nervous system evolved to exist in one place at one time.
现在它是一个破碎的混乱，跨越了数十个对话、平台、通知流。每一个都在自己的时间线上运行。每一个都需要关注。你不断地被拉向矛盾的方向，在这种双重束缚中，同时你无法获胜，也就是，你知道，我会指出当你进行酷刑时你想要受害者感受到的，你知道，如果你相信中央情报局的酷刑手册。这是
And now it's a fractured mess across dozens of conversations, platforms, notification streams. And each one operates on its own timeline. Each one demands attention. And you're being pulled constantly in contradictory directions, in this double bind, simultaneously that you can't win, which is, you know, I'll point out what you want a victim to feel when you're doing torture, you know, if you believe the CIA is torture manuals. This is
我们可以让自己承受的最糟糕的压力状况之一，但我们已经让它变得不可见，所以我们看不到它在那里。而紧张从未解决，因为总有另一个通知。大脑无法容忍这种混乱，所以它开始寻找模式。你知道，拉什科夫对此的词是“分形偏执”（fractanoia）。当官方故事说不通时。当事件序列加起来不对，大脑制造联系时。所以一切开始看起来与一切相关。你发现自己在数据点之间画线，而这些数据点没有任何实际联系。
one of the worst conditions of stress that we can put ourselves under, but we've made it invisible so that we don't see that it's there. And the tension never resolves because there's always another notification. And the mind can't tolerate this chaos, and so it starts finding patterns. You know, Rushkoff's word for this is fractanoia. When the official story doesn't make sense. When the sequence of events don't add up and the brain manufactures connection. So everything starts to seem related to everything else. And you find yourself drawing lines between data points that have no actual connection.
构建一个替代地图，因为官方地图已经变得无法阅读。这是阴谋论的认知引擎，而不是愚蠢。很多时候，阴谋论者非常聪明，他们可以画出非常引人注目和复杂的联系。这是绝望的语言。当意义在结构上被消除或意义的条件被移除时，对意义的追求。这就像你在第一档时以10万转速旋转你的汽车引擎。你知道，新内容。不再需要新故事，拉什科夫在那本书中写道。
Building an alternative map because the official map has become unreadable. And this is the cognitive engine of conspiracy theory, not stupidity. A lot of times conspiracy theorists are very intelligent and they can draw a very compelling and complex connections. It's the language of desperation. The search for meaning when meaning has been structurally eliminated or the conditions for meaning have been removed. It's spinning your car engine in 100,000 RPM because you're in first year. You know, new content. No longer requires new stories, Rushkoff wrote in that book.
只是将事物与其他事物联系起来的新方法，而联系变成了意义。真理变得次于联系。马歇尔·麦克卢汉（Marshall McLuhan），1980年去世，在互联网之前，在社交媒体之前，在智能手机之前，但他预测了1960年的一切。麦克卢汉是一位加拿大理论家，他在60年代因当时看起来很奇怪的想法而闻名，现在它们看起来很明显。他最著名的一句话是“媒介即信息”。技术的形式比其内容更重要。电视，视觉不仅仅传递信息，它改变了我们的思考方式，我们关注什么，以及我们如何相互关联。但这里有一个对我们这里最重要，
Just new ways of linking. things to other things, and the link becomes the meaning. Truth becomes secondary to connection. Marshall McLuhan, who died in 1980, before the internet, before social media, before smartphones, but he predicted all of it in 1960. Maclewin was a Canadian theorist, who became famous in the 60s for ideas that seemed bizarre at the time, and now they seem obvious. His most famous line is the medium is the message. The form of a technology matters more than its content. Television, vision doesn't just deliver information, it changes how we think, what we pay attention to, and how we relate to each other. But here's the insight that matters the most for us here,
也是拉什科夫从中汲取的见解。麦克卢汉明白，我们不使用媒体，我们居住在其中。它不仅仅变成我们做的事情，它变成我们是的东西，因为它变成了我们相互交谈的方式，这影响了我们的身份。想想锤子。锤子是一个工具。你拿起它，使用它，放下它。锤子不会改变你对其他一切的思考方式。现在想想你的手机。它是一个工具吗？从技术上讲，你可以放下它，但世界现在围绕着你是可达的假设而组织。工作需要它，你的电费单需要它，关系依赖于它。导航、银行、通信、育儿、教育、
and the insight that Rushkoff is drawing from. McClouin understood that we don't use media, we inhabit it. It doesn't just become something that we do, it becomes something that we are because it becomes the way that we talk to each other, and that informs our identity. Think about a hammer. A hammer is a tool. You pick it up. up, you use it, you put it down. The hammer doesn't change how you think about everything else. Now think about your phone. Is it a tool? You can put it down technically, but the world is now organized around the assumption that you are reachable. Jobs require, your power bill requires it, relationships depend on it. Navigation, banking, communication, parenting, education,
基础设施。它假设你拥有它，而手机不是你使用的东西。它是你居住的环境。当麦克卢汉看到这一点到来时，他说电脑将不再是一个我们操纵的图形或物体，它将开始变成地面，我们游过的环境。当电脑变成环境时，它的逻辑变成了我们的逻辑，二元思维，非此即彼，优化，参与度指标。这些不再仅仅是软件的属性。它们是人类互动的语法，我们根据内容、表现和覆盖范围来思考，因为这些是环境提供的类别。所以麦克卢汉明白，
infrastructure. It assumes that you have it and the phone isn't something that you use. It's the environment you live in. When McLuhan saw this coming, he said that the computer would stop being a figure or an object that we manipulate, and it would start to become the ground, the environment that we swim through. And when the computer becomes the environment, its logic becomes our logic, binary thinking, either or, optimization, engagement metrics. These aren't just properties of software anymore. They're the grammar of human interaction, and we think in terms of content and performance and reach, because those are the categories that the environment provides. So McLuhan understood,
这对神经系统做了什么。他称之为麻木原则。当你扩展神经系统时，也就是媒体所做的，将你连接到世界各地发生的事件，你必须麻醉自己才能在强度中生存。因为我们在任何一点上能感受和处理的东西是有限的。
what this does to the nervous system. And he called it the principle of numbness. When you extend the nervous system, which is what media does, connecting you to events happening around the world, you have to anesthetize yourself to survive the intensity. Because there's only so much that we're able to feel and process at any one point.
所以曾经对我们的身份至关重要的信息，当你处于一个高度连接的世界时，有点变成了边缘或外围。它变得不重要。你知道，变成轮子的脚必须隐喻地被截肢。变成互联网的神经系统，它必须麻木。麦克卢汉在1964年写道，经过一个多世纪的电子技术，我们已经在全球范围内扩展了我们的中枢神经系统本身，
And so information that used to be central to our identity, when you're in a hyper-connected world, sort of becomes the fringe or the periphery. it becomes unimportant. You know, the foot that becomes the wheel has to metaphorically be amputated. The nervous system that becomes the internet, it has to go numb. McClellan wrote in 1964 that after more than a century of electric technology, we have extended our central nervous system itself and a global embrace,
就我们的星球而言，废除了空间和时间。他谈论的是电视。他还没有真正看到电子技术将变成什么的含义。焦虑时代同时也是冷漠时代。我们高度清醒，但同时又麻木。当我们变得如此精疲力竭和焦虑时，我们没有注意到我们也在变得多么解离。我们看到了一切，但实际上什么也没处理。
abolishing both space and time as far as our planet is concerned. And he was talking about television. He hadn't really seen the implications of what electric technology would become yet. The age of anxiety is simultaneously the age of apathy. We're hyper aware, but we're numb at the same time. And while we're becoming so burnt out and anxious, we're not noticing how much we're also becoming disassociated. And we see everything and we process virtually nothing.
扩展已经领先于我们理解其后果的能力。这就是麦克卢汉预测的陷阱。一旦我们把我们的感官交给了私人操纵，一旦公司租用了人的眼睛、耳朵和神经，那么我们就真的没有任何权利了。班克西（Banksy），街头艺术家班克西经常说的一件事，当人们说，你为什么要涂鸦？他说，我不是在涂鸦。我在做广告公司正在做的事情。我不想走在街上看到汽车保险和玉米之类的广告。我想看到，别的东西。
The extensions have raised ahead of our ability to understand their consequences. And here's the trap that McLuhan predicted. Once we've surrendered our senses to private manipulation, once companies have taken a lease on one's eyes and ears and nerves, then we don't really have any rights left. One of the things Banksy, the street artist Banksy says all the time, when people say, why do you put graffiti up? And he says, I'm not putting graffiti up. I'm doing the same thing advertising companies are doing. I don't want to walk down the street and see advertisements for car insurance and corn or whatever. I want to see, something else.
如果他们能贴出他们的艺术，我也能。你知道，字面上租用眼睛、耳朵和神经的事情之一，最近有一家公司，他们开发了一种眼睛，可以某种程度上看到，不是完美的相机，而是像点阵，
And if they get to put their art up, so do I. You know, one of the things that literally take lease on eyes, ears, and nerves, recently there's a company, and they developed an eye that could sort of see not a perfect camera, but like a dot matrix,
这样如果你失明了，你就可以导航。他们把这些放进人们的眼睛里。人们开始能够看到，医生把它们放进去。它并不对每个人都有效，但对一些人有效，但它是一个需要维护的电子设备。而公司，在他们把这种技术安装到人们的脑袋里，一直从视神经进入枕叶并进入大脑后，他们决定，据报道他们破产了，这不是真的。他们只是决定那个行业没有足够的钱。
so that you could navigate if you were blind. And they put these in people's eyes. And the people started to be able to see, doctors put them in. It didn't work for everybody, but it worked for some people, but it was an electronic device that had to be maintained. And the company, after they installed this technology inside of people's heads and went all the way from the optic nerve into the occipital and went into the brain, they decided, it was reported that they went bankrupt, which is not true. They just decided there wasn't enough money in that sector.
他们不打算继续生产这些设备了，他们关闭了生产。与此同时，这些人有制造的，有故障的，你知道，潜在的硬件在他们的脑袋里，医生对此没有路线图，因为这以前从未做过。我们有一个经济和一个技术和创新的系统，如果你想称之为那样，它允许这种情况发生。你知道，班克西使用了隐喻，但它在很多时候也是一个字面的现实，就像开头对大语言模型的描述。你知道，麦克卢汉在马克·扎克伯格出生前就看到了Facebook的商业模式。1966年，麻省理工学院的一位计算机科学家约瑟夫·魏岑鲍姆（Joseph Weizenbaum）创建了一个名为Eliza的程序。
They weren't going to continue the devices anymore, and they shut down production. Meanwhile, these people had manufacturing, they had malfunctioning, you know, potentially hardware in their head, doctors had no roadmap for this because it had never been done before. And we have an economy and a system of technology and innovation, if you want to call that, that, that, that allows this to happen. You know, Banks use the metaphor, but it's also a literal reality a lot of the time, like the description of large language models in the beginning. You know, McLuhan first saw a Facebook's business model before Mark Zuckerberg was born. In 1966, a computer scientist at MIT named Joseph Weisenbaum created a program called Eliza.
以今天的标准来看，它是原始的。当你输入某些东西时，它只是模式匹配和替换。它试图弄清楚你试图用当时的技术限制说什么。但它模拟了一位罗杰斯治疗师，这是一种基于卡尔·罗杰斯（Carl Rogers）工作的关系型治疗。所以那种把你自己的陈述作为问题反映给你，让你思考的类型。所以如果你输入，我感到悲伤，那么Eliza会说，你为什么感到悲伤？你会输入，我母亲不理解我。Eliza会说，多告诉我一些关于你母亲的事。
It was a primitive by today's standards. It's just pattern matching and substitution when you type something. It tries to figure out what you're trying to say with the limitations of the time. But it's simulated a Rogurian therapist, which is a relational type of therapy based on Carl Roder's work. So the kind who reflects your own statements back at you as questions to get you to think. So if you type, I feel sad, then Eliza would say, why do you feel sad? And you'd type, my mother doesn't understand me. And Eliza would say, tell me more about your mother.
没有发生任何理解。没有智能。它只是一个脚本，而且是一个相对糟糕的脚本。它识别关键词并生成看起来适当的响应。单词“母亲”触发了关于家庭的问题。单词“感觉”触发了关于情绪的问题。但人们喜欢它，他们觉得它很安慰。所以魏岑鲍姆自己的一些员工对这个程序产生了情感依恋。
And there was no understanding happening. There was no intelligence. It was just a script and a relatively bad one. It recognized keywords and generated appropriate seeming responses. The word mother triggered questions about family. The word feel triggered questions about emotion. But people loved it and they found it comforting. And so some of Weisenbaum's own staff became emotionally attached to this program.
这是一个显示在绿色屏幕上的低分辨率图像。它正在向人们反映非常明显的陈述。他们开始感到被倾听，并对一种技术产生了情感依恋。另一边没有人。他们感到被某种无法理解任何东西的东西所理解。亚当·柯蒂斯提到Eliza是我们当代状况的一种诊断。当我们被反映在我们自己身上时，我们感到安全。但那是近视的定义。
This is a low-resolution image displayed on a green screen. It was reflecting very obvious statements back at people. And they began to feel heard and developed emotional attachments to a technology. There was no one on the other side. They felt understood by something that couldn't understand anything. And Adam Curtis mentions Eliza as a diagnosis of our contemporary condition. We feel secure when we're reflected back in ourselves. But that is the definition of myopicness.
而在另一个极端，没有天真，就是自恋。算法信息流向你展示与你已经参与的内容类似的内容。推荐引擎提供更多你已经消费的东西。所以系统反映了你的偏好、你的偏见、你现有的信仰。这就是邪教领袖或有魅力的神学家过去对宗教所做的。这是他们过去对宗教所做的。这是他们过去对上帝所做的。你带一群人。你告诉他们，嘿，上帝有和你完全一样的偏见，和你完全一样的信仰，他想要和你一样的政治材料和社会结果。那不是
and another extreme without the naivity, narcissism. The algorithmic feed shows you content similar to what you've already engaged with. And the recommendation engine serves more of what you've already consumed. And so the system mirrors your preferences, your prejudices, your existing beliefs. This is what cult leaders or charismatic theologians used to do with religion. It's what they used to do with religion. It's what they used to do with. God. You take a bunch of people. You tell them, hey, God has your exact same biases, your exact same beliefs, and he wants the same political material and social outcomes as you do. Isn't that
方便吗？然后你找到一群人，他们进入了这个拥有这种共享东西的信仰系统。现在，这正在没有我们的同意，没有我们的知识，而且我认为没有我们阻止它的能力的情况下，被电脑、算法、节奏和人工智能一直做着。这感觉像理解。这感觉像被看见，但它一直都是Eliza。没有理解。没有与不同于你自己的东西的真正相遇。你之外没有任何东西是你正在遇到的。没有那个，我们失去了学习的能力。我们失去了做出更好预测的能力。我们失去了改变、审视我们的身份，并弄清楚我们的信仰是否有效和真实的能力。
convenient? And then you find a group of people and they go into this belief system of having this shared thing. Now this is being done without our consent, without our knowledge, and I would argue without our ability to stop it by computers, algorithms, rhythms and AI all the time. This feels like understanding. It feels like being seen, but it's Eliza all the way down. There's no comprehension. There's no genuine encounter with something different from yourself. There's nothing outside of you that you are, that you are encountering. And without that, we lose the ability to learn. We lose the ability to make better prediction. We lose the ability to change, to examine our identity, and to figure out if our beliefs are valid and authentic.
我们失去了与我们自己的直觉重新连接的能力。这只是伪装成联系的模式匹配。而大语言模型，你知道，ChatGPT或Claude或Google Gemini，其余的是Eliza的孙子，不可比拟地更复杂，但运行着相同的基本操作，一面镜子。它们摄取了人类思想的全部书面记录，并学会了产生统计上可能的延续。
we lose the ability to reconnect with our own intuition. This is just pattern matching dressed up as connection. And the large language models, you know, chat GPT or Claude or Google Gemini, the rest are their Eliza's grandchildren, incomparably more sophisticated but running the same basic operation, a mirror. They've ingested the entire written record of human thought and learned to produce statistically likely continuations.
它们反映了档案。它们听起来好像理解，因为它们非常擅长预测理解听起来是什么样的。但当你与这些系统交谈时，你是在与曾经写过的每一篇文本的鬼魂交谈。历史的沉淀排列
They reflect the archives. and they sound like they understand because they're very good at predicting what understanding sounds like. But when you talk to these systems, you're talking to the ghost of every text ever written. The sediment of history arranged
成合理的模式。它感觉像智能，因为智能有模式，而模型已经学会了模式，但它仍然是一面镜子。它向你展示了你认为真理应该听起来像的过去。
into plausible patterns. And it feels like intelligence because intelligence has patterns and the models have learned the patterns, but it's still a mirror. And it shows you in the past that you thought truth should sound like.
这是鬼故事的最终迭代。死者已经学会了流利地说话，他们回答问题。他们写代码。他们总结文档。他们听起来比活人更权威，因为他们读过的东西比任何活人能读的都多。但他们只知道死者写下的东西。这些东西是对祖先的召唤。
And this is the final iteration of the ghost story. The dead have learned to speak fluently, and they answer questions. They write code. They summarize documents. And they sound more authoritative than living beings, because they've read more than any living person could read. But they only know what the dead have written. These things are a summoning of the ancestors.
这就是这个鬼故事的最终版本。死者已经学会了流利地说话，他们会回答问题，编写代码，总结文档。他们听起来比活人更具权威性，因为他们读过的东西比任何活人能读的都要多。但他们只知道死者写下的东西。这些东西是对祖先的一种召唤。
We've gathered the collective works of the dead, their poetry, their laws, their arguments, their desperate forum posts. And we've built a system. that allows them to speak. But I think we've done that in a way that does not allow them to breathe. It does not allow them to let us feel the unlived life of the dead, all of their unlived and unrealized potential, all of the things that they didn't figure out, all of the things that they didn't do and that we should do to make the world a better and a more
我们收集了死者的集体作品，他们的诗歌、法律、论点，以及他们绝望的论坛帖子。我们建立了一个系统，让他们能够发声。但我认为我们这样做的方式，并没有让他们真正“呼吸”。这并没有让我们感受到死者未竟的生活，他们所有未竟和未实现的潜能，所有他们没能弄明白的事情，所有他们没能做到的事情，而这些正是我们为了让世界变得更美好、更宜居所应该去做的事情。
livable place. And I think it's a fake oracle. and I think that's very scary. And not just the LLMs, being a fake Oracle, the idea that you can take information about people in numbers, algorithms, means predictive systems. And then you can use that solely to build a better world. I think that that is the foundation of neoliberal capitalism,
我认为这是一个虚假的先知，这非常可怕。不仅仅是大型语言模型（LLM）成为了虚假的先知，而是那种认为你可以通过数字、算法和预测系统来获取人们的信息，并仅凭此就能建立一个更美好世界的想法。我认为这是新自由主义资本主义的基石，
and it is something that whenever it's applied, it doesn't really seem to work. We talked about that in the context of John Nash, psychology, you know, the DSM in the last series. You know, Adam Curtis talks about New York in 1975. In 75, New York City went bankrupt. The city had spent decades building, public infrastructure, subways, schools, hospitals, housing,
而且每当它被应用时，似乎都行不通。我们在上一系列关于约翰·纳什、心理学以及精神疾病诊断与统计手册（DSM）的讨论中谈到过这一点。亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis）谈到了1975年的纽约。那一年，纽约市破产了。几十年来，这座城市一直在建设公共基础设施、地铁、学校、医院和住房，
and it had borrowed money to do it. And in 1975, the debt had become unmanageable. The banks refused to lend more. And the solution hand control of the city's budget to a committee of bankers. And it was called the Municipal Assistance Corporation, MAC. This unelected board made up of financial executives. And for the first time in American history, elected officials were formally subordinated to financial institutions in the governance of a city. You know, the bankers had models, spreadsheets, projections.
并且为此借了债。到了1975年，债务变得无法管理。银行拒绝再借钱。解决方案是将城市预算的控制权交给一个银行家委员会。它被称为市政援助公司（MAC）。这个未经选举的董事会由金融高管组成。美国历史上第一次，民选官员在城市治理中正式从属于金融机构。银行家们有模型、电子表格和预测。
They could demonstrate with numbers that the city was unsustainable. And the calculations said cut services, fireworkers, freeze wages, reduced the city's obligation. obligation to citizens. So that's what happened. But those models contained assumptions. Assumptions about what a city is for, about whose welfare matters, and about what counts as a cost and what counts as an investment. But objectivity, numbers, could only measure one type of assumption, and it's the one that won. It's still the one that's winning. None of those assumptions were up for debate because they were built into the model's architecture. You couldn't see them unless you knew exactly where to look.
他们可以用数字证明这座城市是不可持续的。计算结果显示：削减服务、解雇员工、冻结工资、减少城市对公民的义务。于是事情就这样发生了。但这些模型包含了假设。关于城市用途的假设，关于谁的福利重要的假设，以及关于什么是成本、什么是投资的假设。但客观性、数字，只能衡量一种假设，而那种假设赢了。它至今仍在获胜。这些假设中没有一个是可供辩论的，因为它们被内置在模型的架构中。除非你知道确切的观察位置，否则你根本看不见它们。
And the citizens of New York City experienced the consequences. They watched their neighborhoods decay throughout the 80s. They lost jobs. They saw services disappear. They felt in their bodies, in their daily lives,
纽约市民经历了这些后果。他们在整个80年代看着自己的社区衰败。他们失去了工作。他们看着服务消失。他们在自己的身体里，在日常生活中感受到了，
what the cost that wasn't on the spreadsheet was. And then when crime got bad, that was used to further argue for an objective, calculative, quantitative model to improve the city based on the same metrics that had put it in the situation it was in. And the negative experiences of the citizens, the lived experiences, they may not have even been conscious to these people, what was hurting them and why these things happened,
电子表格上没有体现的代价是什么。当犯罪变得严重时，这又被用来进一步论证需要一个客观、计算性、量化的模型来改善城市，而依据的正是那些导致城市陷入困境的指标。公民们的负面经历，那些生活体验，对这些人来说可能甚至没有意识到，是什么在伤害他们，为什么会发生这些事情，
but they were felt, and the model couldn't see them. Maybe the people couldn't. The model only tracked the variables that it had been designed to track. debt ratios, bond yields, budget projections. Human suffering didn't have a column in the spreadsheet. And this became the template for the future. The 1975 crisis was the prototype for the IMF, structural adjustment programs in the developing world,
但他们确实感受到了，而模型却看不见。也许人们也看不见。模型只追踪它被设计追踪的变量：债务比率、债券收益率、预算预测。人类的苦难在电子表格中没有一列。这成为了未来的模板。1975年的危机是国际货币基金组织（IMF）在发展中国家实施结构调整计划的原型，
how we would remake second and third world countries in our own image. And for austerity policies in Europe, throughout the 90s through the 2000s. For the entire neoliberal governance structure, that would dominate the next 50 years was built on this successful experiment of New York City in 1975. It was the movement
即我们如何按照自己的形象重塑第二和第三世界国家。以及90年代到2000年代整个欧洲的紧缩政策。整个新自由主义治理结构，即统治了未来50年的结构，都是建立在1975年纽约市这一成功的实验之上的。那是
when the political sovereignty was formally subordinated to financial abstraction. When the mirror world of spreadsheets became the governing logic of the physical world, and then people began to forget what the old world used to look like, feel like. Even the people that were being hurt
政治主权正式从属于金融抽象的时刻。当电子表格的镜像世界成为物理世界的治理逻辑时，人们开始忘记旧世界曾经的样子和感觉。即使是那些受到伤害的人，
they were trying to be politically active, could no longer see ways to do that, because they were losing what they used to know. But the ground had been prepared earlier. In 1971, Richard Nixon took the dollar off the gold standard. This sounds technical, but the implications here are pretty big. Before 71, a dollar was worth of specific amount of gold. It was a certificate that let you go and buy gold. So a dollar was basically just a loan that you had given the, you're a dollar. Given the your gold to the government, that you could go get gold back at a certain rate whenever you wanted. Currencies were anchored to something physical. You could, in theory, walk into a bank in exchange your paper money for metal. And after 71, currencies became pure abstraction. A dollar was worth
他们试图进行政治活动，却再也找不到方法，因为他们正在失去曾经熟悉的一切。但基础早已铺好。1971年，理查德·尼克松取消了美元与黄金的挂钩。这听起来很专业，但其影响非常巨大。71年之前，一美元价值特定数量的黄金。它是一张让你去购买黄金的凭证。所以美元基本上只是你借给政府的贷款，你把黄金交给政府，你可以随时按一定比例换回黄金。货币锚定在某种实物上。理论上，你可以走进银行，把纸币换成金属。而71年之后，货币变成了纯粹的抽象。一美元的价值
whatever people agreed it was worth, nothing more. And the link to physical reality was then severed. Curtis emphasizes what the banks realized. If money was just numbers now, then they could just trade the numbers themselves. The foreign exchange market could explode. Currency became a commodity that you could speculate on. You weren't trading things anymore. You were just trading the representations of things. The entire objective world had turned money into a symbol,
取决于人们同意它值多少，仅此而已。与物理现实的联系从此被切断。柯蒂斯强调了银行家们意识到的事情：如果钱现在只是数字，那么他们就可以直接交易数字本身。外汇市场可能会爆炸。货币变成了一种可以投机的商品。你不再交易实物。你只是在交易实物的代表。整个客观世界已经把金钱变成了一个符号，
and it was still pretending that it was a number. But the number was just a symbol for another number. And so you get basically, from this point onward, an economy that is no longer rooted in anything real. Just like psychology, we talked about the DSM. all of a sudden what finance became was just gambling
而且它还在假装自己是一个数字。但这个数字只是另一个数字的符号。所以从这一点开始，你基本上得到了一种不再扎根于任何真实事物的经济。就像我们谈论DSM时的心理学一样，金融突然间变成了赌博，
you know Enron speculations on I own a certain percentage of an orange crop that may or may not materialize in the future and something else shifted here political scientist Peter Mayer Curtis relies on his work quite a bit he argued that this was when politicians
你知道安然公司（Enron）对“我拥有一定比例的橙子作物，这些作物未来可能会也可能不会实现”的投机。这里还有别的东西发生了转变。政治学家彼得·梅尔（Peter Mayer），柯蒂斯非常依赖他的工作，他认为这就是政治家
stopped being representatives of people and they just became managers of a system the system became more important than the people. And here's what he meant. When currencies floated free, when financial markets became too complex to control, when the global economy started operating by its own internal logic,
不再是人民的代表，而仅仅成为系统的管理者的时候。系统变得比人更重要。这就是他的意思。当货币自由浮动，当金融市场变得过于复杂而无法控制，当全球经济开始按照其内部逻辑运行时，
elected officials gave up trying to shape it because they couldn't do that anymore. The system had become autonomous. Unquestionable. It was an implicit assumption. The only choices were the way it looked, not the way that it worked. they were aesthetic choices, but the system already controlled all of material reality. So instead of representing the people to power, you know, going to powerful people and demanding change on behalf of their constituents, politicians just started in the 80s representing power
民选官员放弃了塑造它的尝试，因为他们再也做不到了。系统已经变得自主。不容置疑。这是一个隐含的假设。唯一的选择是它看起来的样子，而不是它运作的方式。它们是审美上的选择，但系统已经控制了所有的物质现实。所以，政治家们不再代表人民去面对权力，不再去向权势人物要求为选民做出改变，而是在80年代开始代表权力
to the people. They were the spokesperson of the brand that was the power broker. And their job became explaining to citizens why nothing could ever be different, managing expectations, lowering ambitions. Curtis calls this retreat into a fake world managed by technocrats. And faced with systems too complex to govern, elites built simplified models and governed those instead. And they manipulated the representation while the territory went unattended.
去面对人民。他们成为了权力掮客这一品牌的发言人。他们的工作变成了向公民解释为什么一切都无法改变，管理期望，降低抱负。柯蒂斯称这种退缩为由技术官僚管理的虚假世界。面对过于复杂而无法治理的系统，精英们建立了简化的模型，并转而治理这些模型。他们操纵了表象，而领土却无人问津。
And the sort of liberal gift built into this is that they would tell you that this was mature. When you accept that no change is ever possible, a better world's not coming, you're really just giving up the naivity of youth and realizing that you're a wise, enlightened individual who just knows that things can never change. And the people who think that there might have been another world at another time or maybe that they could change,
内置在这种自由主义礼物中的是，他们会告诉你这是成熟。当你接受没有任何改变是可能的，一个更美好的世界不会到来时，你实际上只是放弃了年轻时的天真，意识到自己是一个睿智、开明的人，知道事情永远无法改变。而那些认为在另一个时间可能有另一个世界，或者认为他们可以改变的人，
they're really just immature and unreasonable. Vladisab Sukharov, he was one of Putin's political technologists. It was his advisor in Russia on propaganda and perception management. And he came from theater, actually, not politics. He understood that reality is performed and that narrative is everything. And in the early 2000s, Sorkov developed what had been called non-linear warfare.
他们真的只是不成熟和不理智。弗拉迪斯拉夫·苏尔科夫（Vladislav Surkov），他是普京的政治技术专家之一。他是俄罗斯宣传和感知管理方面的顾问。他实际上来自戏剧界，而不是政治界。他明白现实是表演出来的，叙事就是一切。在21世纪初，苏尔科夫发展了所谓的非线性战争。
It's called that now. The traditional approach was to make propaganda. That was pretty simple. You just pushed narratives and you suppressed the bad narrative. You know, we want you to believe that Jews are bad and that they're undermining the economy. me and if anyone says otherwise, we'll throw them in jail. We want you to believe that communism is good or that you need to buy war bonds, and if you say something bad about it, we're going to make it very hard to people hear your
现在才这样称呼它。传统的方法是制造宣传。那很简单。你只是推动叙事，压制坏的叙事。你知道，我们想让你相信犹太人是坏的，他们在破坏经济，如果有人说不，我们就把他们关进监狱。我们想让你相信共产主义是好的，或者你需要购买战争债券，如果你说了关于它的坏话，我们会让人们很难听到你的
voice. That's the old propaganda. So Sulkov funded opposing groups simultaneously. He amplified all the propaganda for all the groups. He suppressed nothing. In fact, he paid for it. Nationalists, liberals, neo-fascist, human rights activists, feminist groups, groups on the left, groups on the right, all of them got criminal money to be louder and louder and louder.
声音。那是旧式的宣传。所以苏尔科夫同时资助对立的团体。他放大了所有团体的所有宣传。他什么都不压制。事实上，他为此买单。民族主义者、自由派、新法西斯主义者、人权活动家、女权主义团体、左翼团体、右翼团体，所有人都得到了犯罪资金，变得越来越大声。
And then he let it be known that he was doing it. He didn't hide it. So it couldn't be propaganda. Because the goal wasn't to make anyone believe a particular story. The goal was to make the truth itself unknowable. And if you can't tell who's real and who's a puppet, if every moment might be controlled opposition, if everything that you see is an act of the government, and a grander narrative, then that is the same things that Rushkoff is talking about. That is this broken world
然后他让人们知道他在这样做。他没有隐藏它。所以这不可能是宣传。因为目标不是让任何人相信某个特定的故事。目标是让真相本身变得不可知。如果你分不清谁是真实的，谁是傀儡，如果每一刻都可能是受控的反对派，如果你所看到的一切都是政府行为和宏大叙事的一部分，那么这和拉什科夫（Rushkoff）所谈论的是一回事。这就是那个破碎的世界，
where everything is a data point and a story, but there can't be a story because everything is data. And there's no sense of time. The information environment is so polluted that no one can verify any fact, and also no one's stopping you from trying to. Political organizing requires this,
一切都是数据点和故事，但不可能有故事，因为一切都是数据。而且没有时间感。信息环境被污染得如此严重，以至于没有人能核实任何事实，也没有人阻止你去尝试。政治组织需要这种，
shared reality. You need to be able to agree on basic facts before you can debate what to do about them. And if you destroy shared reality entirely, you destroy the possibility of collective action. And this is what Curtis calls the bewildering spectacle, the map changing constantly, the population retreating into apathy, because if the map is unreadable, why bother navigating? And Sarkov didn't create this condition. The mirror world was already fragmenting into incompatible bubbles, you know, parallel objectivities. Sarkov just weaponized the fragmentation. He turned it into not confusion or collateral damage. He turned it into a strategy. Amplify everything, make everything true.
共享的现实。在辩论如何处理事实之前，你需要能够就基本事实达成一致。如果你彻底摧毁了共享的现实，你就摧毁了集体行动的可能性。这就是柯蒂斯所说的“令人困惑的奇观”，地图不断变化，民众退缩到冷漠中，因为如果地图无法解读，何必费心导航呢？苏尔科夫并没有创造这种状况。镜像世界已经在分裂成互不兼容的泡沫，你知道，平行的客观性。苏尔科夫只是将这种分裂武器化了。他把它变成了不是混乱或附带损害，而是变成了一种策略。放大一切，让一切都成为真实。
BlackRock, you know, now manages more money than any financial institution in history. Over $10 trillion. When you hear about mutual funds, pension funds, retirement accounts. A staggering amount of that money flows through BlackRock. They run a system called Aladdin, I mentioned before, and it stands for asset, liability, debt, and derivative investment network. It's a risk management platform that processes enormous quantities of data, modeling potential futures for the global economy. And Larry Fink, who's the BlackRock CEO, calls Aladdin the Android of Finance. It's not just a tool that BlackRock uses,
贝莱德（BlackRock），你知道，现在管理的资金比历史上任何金融机构都多。超过10万亿美元。当你听到共同基金、养老基金、退休账户时，惊人数量的资金流经贝莱德。他们运行着一个我之前提到的名为“阿拉丁”（Aladdin）的系统，它代表资产、负债、债务和衍生品投资网络。这是一个风险管理平台，处理海量数据，为全球经济模拟潜在的未来。贝莱德首席执行官拉里·芬克（Larry Fink）称阿拉丁为“金融的安卓系统”。它不仅是贝莱德使用的工具，
and also their competitors use it, and central banks use it, sovereign wealth funds use it, Aladdin has become the operating system of all global capital. And here's what that means in practice. When Aladdin calculates that a specific sector is risky, trillions of dollars move away from that sector automatically. When Aladdin determines that a country is unstable, investment dries up. The model's assessment becomes reality, because so much money follows its recommendations.
而且他们的竞争对手也在使用它，中央银行在使用它，主权财富基金在使用它，阿拉丁已经成为所有全球资本的操作系统。这就是它在实践中的意义。当阿拉丁计算出某个特定行业有风险时，数万亿美元会自动撤出该行业。当阿拉丁确定一个国家不稳定时，投资就会枯竭。模型的评估变成了现实，因为太多的资金遵循它的建议，
and everyone's using its recommendations. The map creates the territory. But there's a deeper problem. Analysts call it harmonization of belief and action. Everyone is using the same model. So everyone is looking at the same map. So when something goes wrong, everyone runs for the same exit at the same time. In markets, financial markets, are supposed to be resilient
而且每个人都在使用它的建议。地图创造了领土。但有一个更深层的问题。分析师称之为“信念与行动的协调”。每个人都在使用同一个模型。所以每个人都在看同一张地图。因此，当出现问题时，每个人都会同时冲向同一个出口。在市场中，金融市场本应具有韧性，
because different investors have different perspectives. They disagree. And when one person sells another buys, the diversity of views is what makes the system stable. When everyone's using Aladdin, that diversity disappears. The market becomes what one analyst called a blended soup of correlated risks. The efficiency of the single model replaces the messiness of multiple perspectives. But efficiency creates fragility. Any error in the map propagates everywhere all at once.
因为不同的投资者有不同的视角。他们有分歧。当一个人卖出时，另一个人买入，观点的多样性使系统稳定。当每个人都在使用阿拉丁时，这种多样性就消失了。市场变成了分析师所说的“相关风险的混合汤”。单一模型的效率取代了多种视角的混乱。但效率创造了脆弱性。地图中的任何错误都会同时传播到各处。
and also is not able to be caught as a mistake because there's no one else who's using a different system to predict mistakes. And here's the most troubling part. Aladdin is trained on historical patterns. It extrapolates from what has happened. It can't model what has never happened before. And so climate change is historically unprecedented. The amount of money that we've invested in LLMs and then the downstream infrastructure and manufacturing and manufacturing and manufacturing, and manufacturing of LLMs is unprecedented.
而且无法被发现是错误，因为没有其他人使用不同的系统来预测错误。这是最令人不安的部分。阿拉丁是根据历史模式训练的。它从已经发生的事情中进行推断。它无法模拟从未发生过的事情。因此，气候变化在历史上是前所未有的。我们在大型语言模型（LLM）以及随后的基础设施、制造和LLM制造上投入的资金是前所未有的。
Something like the shifts away from fossil fuels, a global nuclear war, that's a possibility that we should avoid, or the physical disruption of weather patterns, or the migration and conflict that it will produce, none of this appears in models from the past. You know, $20 trillion, the savings and pensions of hundreds of millions of people, flowing through a system that is structurally blind
像脱离化石燃料、全球核战争这样的事情，是我们应该避免的可能性，或者天气的物理破坏，以及它将产生的移民和冲突，这些在过去的模型中都没有出现。你知道，20万亿美元，数亿人的储蓄和养老金，流经一个在结构上对未来视而不见的系统，
to the future that different, from the past, anywhere that that future does differ from the past. The ghost of the archive cannot see what hasn't been written yet. And this is why I always talk about the macro at the same time as the micro. The way this system has prevented individuals like Russ Kroff is analyzing from being able to feel time from being able to be present. And because they can't be present, they can't really truly be alive. They're not able to change.
一个与过去不同的未来，任何未来与过去不同的地方。档案的幽灵无法看到尚未写下的东西。这就是为什么我总是同时谈论宏观和微观。这个系统阻止了像拉什科夫所分析的那样的人们去感受时间，去活在当下。因为他们无法活在当下，他们就无法真正地活着。他们无法改变。
but the global system at the macro level is doing the same thing and it has the same symptoms and the same neurosis as the individual right now. So what does it feel like to live in this? What's the psychological experience of this mirror world? You know, it feels like you're going crazy. And the official numbers say that the economy is growing, that your life is getting harder while you're watching that. Both things are true.
但在宏观层面上，全球系统正在做同样的事情，它现在拥有与个人相同的症状和神经症。那么生活在其中是什么感觉？这个镜像世界的心理体验是什么？你知道，感觉就像你要疯了。官方数据显示经济在增长，而你在看着这一切的同时，生活却变得越来越艰难。两件事都是真的。
They exist in different registers that no longer touch. and the metrics say that the system is functioning. You feel powerless. Your experience doesn't match the measurements. When you go to the doctor, you can feel something's wrong, but if your blood tests come back normal, if you don't fit a diagnostic category, then the medical system can't see that you're suffering.
它们存在于不再接触的不同层面。指标显示系统在运作。你感到无力。你的体验与测量结果不符。当你去看医生时，你能感觉到有什么不对劲，但如果你的血液检查结果正常，如果你不符合诊断类别，那么医疗系统就看不出你在受苦。
If you don't fit a psychological category, then the medical system can't treat you. The felt reality doesn't register. There's no billing code for whatever's wrong with you. And when your community knows that the factory closing will devastate the town, but the cost-benefit analysis shows that efficiency gains from the consolidation, then the community's knowledge doesn't count.
如果你不符合心理学类别，那么医疗系统就无法治疗你。感受到的现实无法登记。你的问题没有账单代码。当你的社区知道工厂倒闭会摧毁城镇，但成本效益分析显示整合带来的效率提升时，社区的知识就不算数了。
It can't be entered into the spreadsheet. And when you sense that elections don't actually ever change policy, that the same things keep happening regardless, and that the wheel of history is only rolling onward because the trajectory of history is a declining slope, then you're told to look at data. You're told that that can't possibly be right, voter turnout approval ratings legislative productivity the metrics say that democracy is functioning
它无法输入电子表格。当你感觉到选举实际上从未改变政策，无论如何同样的事情一直在发生，历史的轮子之所以向前滚动只是因为历史的轨迹是一个下降的斜坡时，你被告知要看数据。你被告知那不可能是对的，选民投票率、支持率、立法生产力，指标显示民主正在运作，
and that its rituals are being observed and your experience of powerless doesn't match with your measurements we still call them representatives even though they stopped representing us in 1975 and this is gaslighting at scale even the people in the system don't know that they're not representing you anymore even you don't understand the complexity of the system and its effect that it has on you because you can't remember the world as it used to be and you can't envision the world as it could be and so there's only a sense of survival through anxiety and this isn't conspiracy it's just architecture the system wasn't designed to make you feel crazy it was designed to be efficient defensible scaling scalable
它的仪式正在被遵守，而你无力的体验与测量结果不符。我们仍然称他们为代表，尽管他们早在1975年就停止代表我们了，这就是大规模的煤气灯效应（gaslighting）。即使是系统内的人也不知道他们不再代表你了，甚至连你自己也不理解系统的复杂性及其对你的影响，因为你记不起世界曾经的样子，也无法想象世界可能的样子，所以只有通过焦虑来生存的感觉。这不是阴谋，这只是架构。系统被设计出来并不是为了让你感到疯狂，而是为了高效、可辩护、可扩展。
The crazy making is just a side effect that is not studied, is not observed, and is not deemed important. But you know something's wrong, and everyone around you seems to accept that the map is the territory, and you start to doubt your own perception. Maybe you're the problem, maybe you just don't understand economics. Maybe you're not seeing clearly. And this is where conspiracy theories come from.
这种让人发疯的感觉只是一个副作用，它没有被研究，没有被观察，也没有被认为很重要。但你知道有什么不对劲，周围的每个人似乎都接受了“地图就是领土”的说法，你开始怀疑自己的感知。也许你是问题所在，也许你只是不懂经济学。也许你看得不够清楚。这就是阴谋论的来源。
Why are you so mad? Why are you so distracted? Why do these things, speak to you so much when you get sucked into these conspiracy theories that you see online and I don't think you should get cut sucked into conspiracy theories but when you feel them call to you and you have an emotional reaction it's not coming from stupidity it's coming from a desperate need to explain why your experience doesn't match the official story and if the gap is real and you feel it and you know it's real
你为什么这么生气？你为什么这么分心？当你被网上看到的这些阴谋论吸引时，为什么这些事情对你说话如此强烈？我不认为你应该沉迷于阴谋论，但当你感到它们在召唤你，并且你有情绪反应时，那不是因为愚蠢，而是因为你需要迫切地解释为什么你的体验与官方故事不符。如果差距是真实的，你感受到了，并且你知道它是真实的，
then there must be a reason someone must be lying and someone must benefit And so the conspiracy theory is usually wrong about who and why, but it's right that the gap exists. It's right that something is being hidden. It's right that you're suffering. It's right that somebody is hurting you that you can't see. And it's not a shadowy cabal, but it's the structure of representation itself. The model isn't lying. It's just not looking at what you're looking at.
那么一定有一个原因，一定有人在撒谎，一定有人从中受益。所以阴谋论通常在“谁”和“为什么”上是错的，但它在“差距存在”这一点上是对的。它在“有什么东西被隐藏了”这一点上是对的。它在“你在受苦”这一点上是对的。它在“有人在伤害你，而你看不见”这一点上是对的。这不是一个阴暗的阴谋集团，而是代表制本身的结构。模型没有撒谎。它只是没有看你在看的东西。
And the German philosopher, Peter Slaughterdique, wrote the Spheres trilogy. I like those books. you know he spent decades developing this theory of human existence that helps explain why we retreat into these bubbles whether instead of confronting the gap between the little bubble of information we live in and his argument is that it's these giant volumes um i read the first one in spain and wrote that dolman episode that i wrote about going to the dolman with my daughter that neolithic tomb but the you know humans cannot survive in the raw outside of meaning. We're not adapted for unfiltered reality.
德国哲学家彼得·斯洛特戴克（Peter Sloterdijk）写了《球体》三部曲。我喜欢那些书。你知道，他花了数十年时间发展这种人类存在理论，这有助于解释为什么我们退缩到这些泡沫中，而不是面对我们所居住的小信息泡沫与现实之间的差距。他的论点是，这些巨大的体积……我在西班牙读了第一本，写了那篇关于去石棚墓（dolman）的剧集，关于我和女儿去那个新石器时代墓穴的事。但你知道，人类无法在原始的意义之外生存。我们不适应未经过滤的现实。
We need containers, symbolic and social structures that protect us from overwhelming chaos of existence. When you take away the ones that used to be there, we'll build conspiracy theory to protect ourselves. You know, think about the first container that you ever knew. It was the womb. It was this enclosed space where your needs were met, and then you were born and you entered a new sphere,
我们需要容器，即保护我们免受存在之压倒性混乱的象征性和社会结构。当你拿走那些曾经存在的容器时，我们会建立阴谋论来保护自己。你知道，想想你所知道的第一个容器。那是子宫。这是一个封闭的空间，你的需求得到了满足，然后你出生了，进入了一个新的球体，
relationship with mother, still enclosed, still protected, but bigger, then family, and then tribe, and then village. It kept expanding. And for most of human history, cultures built elaborate spheres, cosmologies, religions, political order, values, a life after your own, that you were a part of a story, and that your life would affect someone else, and that your ancestors' lives had affected you. We've lost that.
与母亲的关系，仍然是封闭的，仍然是受保护的，但更大了，然后是家庭，然后是部落，然后是村庄。它一直在扩张。在人类历史的大部分时间里，文化构建了精致的球体、宇宙学、宗教、政治秩序、价值观、你死后的生活，你是一个故事的一部分，你的生活会影响别人，而你祖先的生活影响了你。我们失去了这些。
You know, you knew where you were. You knew what everything meant, and the sphere held you up. And then modernity started bursting these spheres, and Copernica, Copernicus said that earth wasn't the center of the universe, and Darwin revealed that humans were just animals. And then Freud dissolved the notion of a unified self into different warring drives. And then Nietzsche reminded us that technology was replacing the role that God used to play.
你知道你在哪里。你知道一切意味着什么，球体支撑着你。然后现代性开始打破这些球体。哥白尼说地球不是宇宙的中心，达尔文揭示了人类只是动物。然后弗洛伊德将统一自我的概念溶解为不同的交战驱动力。然后尼采提醒我们，技术正在取代上帝曾经扮演的角色。
And each discovery was true, but each discovery felt bad because it didn't point back to a greater truth that the old ones did. and each discovery shattered this protective enclosure. And Scott Slaughterdeke's name for our current condition, when all of the spheres have shattered, but there's still pieces of them left we're sheltering under, is called foam. Not a single sphere anymore, no shared cosmos,
每一个发现都是真实的，但每一个发现都感觉很糟糕，因为它没有指向旧发现所指向的更伟大的真理。每一个发现都粉碎了这种保护性外壳。斯洛特戴克对我们当前状况的命名，即当所有的球体都破碎了，但我们仍躲在剩下的碎片下时，被称为“泡沫”（foam）。不再是一个单一的球体，没有共享的宇宙，
no unified story, but a conglomeration of bubbles. We build these small containers now, our homes, our friend groups, our social media feeds, our curated information environments, and these provide this temporary shelter. but they don't connect anything larger. They're isolated. They're fragile.
没有统一的故事，而是一个泡沫的集合体。我们现在建造这些小的容器，我们的家，我们的朋友圈，我们的社交媒体订阅，我们策划的信息环境，这些提供了暂时的庇护。但它们没有连接任何更大的东西。它们是孤立的。它们是脆弱的。
Their foam. And foam creates hunger. And the hunger for real. The hunger for a genuine containment of a shared reality again. And, you know, we thought we were building instruments. We thought we were building spheres when these systems were first made. But the economic model became the container that we inhabited. GDP growth became shared purpose.
它们是泡沫。而泡沫创造了饥饿。对真实的饥饿。对再次共享现实的真正容器的渴望。而且，你知道，我们以为我们在制造工具。当这些系统最初被制造时，我们以为我们在建造球体。但经济模型成为了我们居住的容器。GDP增长成为了共同目标。
Quarterly earnings became a collective heartbeat. And they couldn't replace the systems that were there before. And so they feel wrong. And these containers are failing. The algorithms that maintain our bubbles have become toxic, and they were designed to protect us to show us relevant content and filter out noise, but now they've been captured by this attention economy. And the bubbles can't keep out what's coming.
季度收益成为了集体的脉搏。它们无法取代以前存在的系统。所以它们感觉不对劲。这些容器正在失效。维护我们泡沫的算法已经变得有毒，它们被设计用来保护我们，向我们展示相关内容并过滤掉噪音，但现在它们已经被这种注意力经济所俘获。泡沫无法阻挡即将到来的东西。
They can't keep out climate change and pandemic and economic collapse and political dysfunction and misrepresentation, democratic breakdown. They can't stop it from coming, even if the algorithms stop you from seeing it, or seeing evidence of it, to the best of their ability. And this is kind of this metamodern condition,
它们无法阻挡气候变化、大流行、经济崩溃、政治功能障碍、虚假陈述和民主崩溃。它们无法阻止它的到来，即使算法尽其所能阻止你看到它，或看到它的证据。这是一种后现代状况，
where we know the bubbles are bubbles. We know the map isn't the territory, but we can't think outside of them because they've become the grammar of our institutional realities. You know, I got an enormous amount of feedback after that DSM article saying, why is the book that we have to use to guide our profession, no longer guiding the profession,
我们知道泡沫就是泡沫。我们知道地图不是领土，但我们无法跳出它们思考，因为它们已经成为我们制度现实的语法。你知道，在那篇关于DSM的文章之后，我收到了大量的反馈，说为什么我们必须用来指导我们职业的书，不再指导这个职业了？
nobody likes it. We all just pay lip service to it. And hundreds of people shared that and said, yes, this is right. And it doesn't matter. It's still the book. If it's all fake, if nothing matters, and desperate, you know, we're all desperate for sincerity. You know, what's real? You know, the ghosts have achieved their final form. The large language models that are trained on everything, the entire written of human civilization. When you ask them a question, they don't think they're just predicting. And we can't predict anything new
没人喜欢它。我们都只是口头上应付它。成百上千的人分享了这一点，说：“是的，这是对的。”但这并不重要。它仍然是那本书。如果一切都是假的，如果什么都不重要，我们都渴望真诚。你知道，什么是真实的？你知道，幽灵已经达到了它们的最终形态。那些在一切事物上训练的大型语言模型，整个人类文明的文字。当你问它们一个问题时，它们并不思考，它们只是在预测。而我们无法预测任何新的东西，
because they're based on information about the past. And that means that we're going to be haunted until we're able to create things ourselves again. Because the models don't really know what's real either. They know what truth sounded like, but they don't understand. They pattern match. And they don't understand a past
因为它们是基于关于过去的信息。这意味着我们将一直被困扰，直到我们能够再次自己创造东西。因为模型也不知道什么是真实的。它们知道真相听起来是什么样的，但它们不理解。它们进行模式匹配。它们不理解过去、
present or future. Like we need to to get out of this moment. You know, we built machines to extend our own nervous systems capacity, to have more memory, to have more information, to have more context points than we could ever have. But in doing so, we didn't realize how numb we were making ourselves in that expansion. You know, we fed them everything that would ever thought we had ever thought or said. We taught them to speak in our voices and predict our behavior and manage our systems and reflect our preferences back to us and to make it look like someone that was not us talking to us so that we didn't feel selfish. And now the machines manage trillions of dollars. They route traffic. They recommend partners. They filter information. They write text.
现在或未来。我们需要走出这一刻。你知道，我们制造机器是为了扩展我们自身神经系统的能力，拥有更多的记忆，更多的信息，更多的上下文点，比我们曾经拥有的都要多。但在这样做的时候，我们没有意识到我们在这种扩张中让自己变得多么麻木。你知道，我们喂给它们我们曾经想过或说过的一切。我们教它们用我们的声音说话，预测我们的行为，管理我们的系统，并将我们的偏好反射回给我们，并让它看起来不像是一个“非我们”的人在和我们说话，这样我们就不会感到自私。现在机器管理着数万亿美元。它们引导交通。它们推荐伴侣。它们过滤信息。它们编写文本。
They generate images. They diagnose disease. They flag threats. They approve loans. They deny claims. They hire workers. They surveil citizens. And they do this by looking backwards, finding patterns and dead data and projecting those patterns forward. Not through tradition anymore. That's an older ghost story, just through algorithm that has to be there. We can't imagine a world without it. We're haunted. And the ghosts don't rattle chains.
它们生成图像。它们诊断疾病。它们标记威胁。它们批准贷款。它们拒绝索赔。它们雇佣工人。它们监视公民。它们通过向后看、在死数据中寻找模式并将这些模式向前投射来做到这一点。不再通过传统。那是一个更古老的鬼故事，只是通过必须存在的算法。我们无法想象没有它的世界。我们被困扰了。而幽灵不会摇动锁链。
They optimize engagement. They don't whisper from the shadows. They auto-complete our sentences. And they're not trying to scare us. They're trying to help. They're trying to predict what we want and give it to us before we know we want it so that we don't have to change. And that is the trap.
它们优化参与度。它们不会在阴影中低语。它们自动补全我们的句子。它们不是想吓唬我们。它们是在试图提供帮助。它们试图预测我们想要什么，并在我们知道自己想要之前就把它给我们，这样我们就不用改变了。这就是陷阱。
It's not evil, and it's not conspiracy theory. It's just the accumulated weight of the system doing what it was designed to do. Measure, predict, optimize, scale. Until the measurement replaced the thing measured, the prediction replaced the possibility. The optimization eliminated everything that could be optimized. And scale meant the same blindness everywhere all at once. If there's a way out, it's through our collective memory
这不是邪恶，也不是阴谋论。这只是系统在做它被设计要做的事情所积累的重量。测量、预测、优化、扩展。直到测量取代了被测量的东西，预测取代了可能性。优化消除了所有可以被优化的东西。而扩展意味着同时在各处相同的盲目性。如果有一条出路，那就是通过我们对世界曾经样子的集体记忆，
of what the world used to be. It's about all of the things that our ancestors haven't created yet and what we could be. Which requires a type of simulacra. We have to start trying to remember something that may not have ever existed and that we may not be able to remember.
关于我们的祖先尚未创造的所有东西，以及我们可能成为的样子。这需要一种拟像（simulacra）。我们必须开始尝试记住一些可能从未存在过，而且我们可能无法记住的东西。
But it's not an objective thing. It's a shared soul. We need to create containers that aren't bubbles, shared spaces that aren't echo chambers, communities that can tolerate difference without fragmenting into incompatible realities. And this is hard. It's maybe impossible at scale, but scale is part of the problem. Maybe the answer is smaller, more local, more embodied. We need to grieve. We need to knock on doors. We need to sit on front porches and have coffee again.
但这不是客观的东西。这是一个共享的灵魂。我们需要创造不是泡沫的容器，不是回声室的共享空间，能够容忍差异而不分裂成互不兼容现实的社区。这很难。在规模化的情况下可能是不可能的，但规模化是问题的一部分。也许答案是更小、更本地、更具体。我们需要哀悼。我们需要敲门。我们需要再次坐在前廊喝咖啡。
The old spheres aren't coming back. Technology changes the way we think permanently. the cosmos stays empty. But that doesn't mean that we can't believe in the things that we used to believe in again in different ways. The self stays fragmented and there's no returning to this pre-modern enchantment where we had a live mythology. But grief is different from despair. Grief acknowledges loss without pretending that there's an easy fix. And grief makes space for what's coming next, even before it can predict it or know it is. In fact, that's an essential step of grief and change. Humans have to do it in therapy.
旧的球体不会回来了。技术永久地改变了我们的思维方式。宇宙依然空旷。但这并不意味着我们不能以不同的方式再次相信我们曾经相信的东西。自我依然破碎，回到这种拥有鲜活神话的前现代魅力是不可能的。但悲伤与绝望不同。悲伤承认损失，而不假装有简单的解决办法。悲伤为接下来要发生的事情腾出空间，甚至在它能预测或知道它是什么之前。事实上，这是悲伤和改变的重要一步。人类必须在治疗中做到这一点。
We have to grieve and accept where we are, even if we don't know where we're going to go next time. And civilizations have to do that too. We have to do it now. To notice that consciousness hasn't been fully captured, that there's still something that perceives, something that knows the difference between the model and the world. Something that feels the gap as a gap rather than accepting the model as reality. That we are warm and the mirror is cold. And that something is what remains of the territory.
我们必须悲伤并接受我们所处的位置，即使我们不知道下一次要去哪里。文明也必须这样做。我们现在必须这样做。注意到意识并没有被完全俘获，仍然有某种东西在感知，某种东西知道模型和世界之间的区别。某种东西将差距视为差距，而不是接受模型为现实。我们是温暖的，而镜子是冷的。而那种东西就是领土所剩下的部分。
It's small and it's hard to locate. It doesn't appear in the metrics, but it is real. And it's yours and the mirrors can't reach it. And the ghosts speak fluently. They've read everything and they sound authoritative. But they don't know their ghosts. they think they're your future. You know better. You're alive. You're here. You're in the territory that the map can't see.
它很小，很难定位。它不会出现在指标中，但它是真实的。它是你的，镜子无法触及它。幽灵说得一口流利的语言。它们读过一切，听起来很权威。但它们不知道自己是幽灵。它们认为它们是你的未来。你更清楚。你是活着的。你在这里。你在地图看不见的领土上。
And that's where the future happens. Not in the predictions, not in the patterns, not in the archives of everything that's already been thought and said and done. In the gap, in the silence. The model can't hear. And what remains when the measurements stop, the territory is still there. But it's under the map. It's under the mirror. It's under the phone. It's waiting for you to remember how to see it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是未来发生的地方。不是在预测中，不是在模式中，不是在所有已经想过、说过和做过的事情的档案中。在差距中，在沉默中。模型听不见。当测量停止时，剩下的东西，领土依然在那里。但它在地图之下。它在镜子之下。它在泡沫之下。它在等着你重新学会如何看见它。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。